j'en ai failli bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france à l'heure
vous dites que vous voulez un carnet de
la joie une belle intention mais au-delà
de cela
quel sens vous donnez à votre
candidature exactement c'est la clown
est de rappeler où je viens d'écouter
vos informations
elles sont effrayantes le monde est un
effroi et en france
nous sommes tous tétanisés mort de peur
dans l' angoisse
il n'y a pas de lendemain les enfants
sont démoralisés leur dieu par à monchy
comme de l'est connaissent et les papas
et mamans ne vont pas mieux
donc il faut apporter un peu de sérénité
dans un premier temps un peu de bon sens
aussi pour calmer un petit peu tout le
monde la france est un grand pays
lorsqu'il est rassemblé
disait en 2017 vous avez obtenu 1,21 %
des voix comment est ce que vous allez
faire passer votre message poser dans
cette élection présidentielle à venir
parce qu'il faut trouver voyez chers van
hamme le mistigri
c'est à dire c'est un petit peu ce que
tout le monde cherche faut regarder la
réalité en face avec ce que je viens
d'entendre soit nous allons retrouver la
situation qu'eux
ses yeux le pire est évité à plusieurs
moments de notre histoire
d'ailleurs le bain de sang qui emportera
des millions de jeunes de femmes déjà il
était pour rien peu après pour faire un
processus de paix soit pour la première
fois en occident nous trouverons un
moyen pacifique de nous remettre
tranquillement retravaillé pour ça je
vous le redis je sais que c'est très
difficile à admettre
il faut créer un climat totalement
différent je dois m'inscrire dans une
rupture par rapport à tout ce qui se
fait depuis 30 ans en france
est ce la raison pour laquelle je veux
d'une certaine manière et avec je ne
prends pas pour un entrain beaucoup de
modestie incarner
l'action du général de gaulle à ce pays
bien sûr nous à 70 ce n'est plus 2021
l'europe n'existait pas le monde a
totalement changé
il n'empêche que la france a besoin
d'hommes et de femmes tissent l'aide
l'un d'entre eux notamment aux cinq
années
ce grand pays et lui redonner un sens et
un futur et jeu des alliances peut-être
avec l heure
[Applaudissements]
avec qui bon écoute on en n'est pas là
parce que pour l'instant heller llr ne
sais pas quel candidat y en avoir il
entendait des régionales et qui n'aura
certainement pas lieu
ces temps compliqués moi je suis
candidat et il ne le sommes pas vous
voulez vous je fasse des accords avec
des jeunes qui pour l'instant ne sont
pas en compétition non moi justement ce
qui me différencie c'est que je suis
dans un livre et indépendant avec une
certaine expérience de même voyez-vous
malade parce que j'ai eu mon premier
mandat à 21 ans j'ai jamais été battu
j'ai créé ma propre entreprise après
avoir été hébergée donc je connais un
peu le match du monde et je ne peux pas
me résoudre à laisser les choses aller à
la catastrophe reconnaît yvon moi je
suis porteur d'une joie intérieure et
c'est ça qu'il faut faire partager c'est
ça qui me permettra d'exposer un site
mon projet mais vous n'êtes pas fermé
aux alliances alors je vais quand même
vous à dire un petit peu plus je passe
maintenant si on veut ramener il faut
pas être fermée aux alliances
il faut savoir qui qui sont les
personnes avec qui avec qui vous voulez
vous que je fasse une alliance à l air
avec madame pécresse avec monsieur
bertrand avec des mèches évoqué avec qui
je ne sais pas moi pour l'instant je me
définis moi même on a trop tendance à se
situer par rapport à pierre paul ou
jacques qui d'ailleurs chante aussi pour
mais que tout le monde il va falloir
quand même récolté des 500 parrainages
pour voir concrétiser votre candidature
c'était compliqué déjà en 2017 vous êtes
confiant
ça sera très compliqué et plus encore
c'est aussi parce que tous ceux que je
rencontre qui sent qu'ils ont fait
quelque chose sont tous candidats à la
présidentielle tout le monde veut sauver
la patrie et si possible le monde la
nano tu as donc ils vont prendre
beaucoup de signatures à vous savez que
les maires ne les donne pas facilement
surtout qu'actuellement ils sont à la
tête de deux de liste arc en ciel autour
les autour des sentiments de la commune
sont représentés tous les sentiments et
et à la toujours en guidant pas jaloux
qui l'aiment pas untel ou unetelle dans
ce 7e but mais j'aimais à côté nos
librairies qui a réussi à les obtenir et
je m'étais pas trop mal classés je
l'avais fait 703 sur près de 90
départements différents
mais c'est un challenge tout dans ce que
je trouve ans aujourd'hui est impossible
à réaliser et d'un possible que j'arrive
à convaincre mais compatriotes qu'il ya
une autre voie
il est impossible d'avoir les signatures
il est impossible après le retrouvons
projet à exécution
et pourtant nous allons le faire parce
que le reste est beaucoup pire encore et
vous aller puiser
le reste si on ne faisait rien la
situation ou est-ce que vous allez puisé
votre lectorat
oui
avec l'électorat il est disponible le
lectorat est déçu
et n'a plus confiance en rien ni à
personne
ils détestent
des hommes et femmes politiques et il ay
les partis politiques parce que il a le
sentiment que c'est des sectes ou des
mafias qui font et défont le monde donc
il ya du boulot hein mais parce qu'entre
le peuple souverain
c'est l'irlande qui ces déclarations
règle a écrit la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen qui a fait de
notre pays un pays universaliste est
disponible pour se remettre au travail
s'il retrouve une raison de vivre une
raison d'espérer
j'en ai ça vous parle beaucoup de ce
duel
marine le pen emmanuel macron au second
tour de cette future présidentielle
coffret vous dans ce cas
mais il n'aura pas lieu vous savez comme
moi que toutes les prévisions de finale
n'ont jamais eu lieu
il y en a aucune qui s'est réalisé il ya
là un des deux est parfois les deux qui
ont été défaillants ad la fois vous
devez avoir
balladur contre jospin
ça n'a été ni l'un ni l'autre voilà bon
qu'est-ce que vous les chevaux disent ça
ne s'est jamais produit bon
ma crainte c'est pas sûr du tout qu'il
le soit pas ce qu'il est arrivé avec un
coup de baguette magique il avait très
envie qui a été choisi par le système
c'est la première fois en france
d'ailleurs qu'on était par terre
apprécié à la république et un premier
ministre sans même les avertir et puis
il a trouvé beaucoup d'argent je sais
pas d'où vient cet argent on le saura
bientôt un peu plus tard on le sait
aujourd'hui pour sarkozy est ce que vous
croyez
est ce que vous croyez à un front
républicain pour faire barrage justement
rassemblement national
mais moi je laisse couler si je commence
à faire des barrages alors que je vous
dis qu'il faut rassembler non
téléspectateurs et auditeurs on dire il
est fou non il faut trouver un minimum
de cohérence
il faut prendre les problèmes tels
qu'ils sont et à partir de ce constat
essayé avec mon sens elle beaucoup d'
écoute beaucoup de patience et une
détermination à toute épreuve de
proposer une voie nouvelle
merci beaucoup jean lassalle je rappelle
que vous porter candidat pour la
présidentielle 2012 vous êtes député de
l'ariège musée circonscription des
pyrénées-atlantiques